first impression you get when holding
Sony's $100 PlayStation classic is that
it's a well-made little device with some
great details on the surface memories of
gaming in the 90s will quickly come
flooding in and if the cute console
wasn't enough that classic and quaint
PlayStation controllers will almost
certainly get you in the mood for some
Tekken 3 and I'll gear solid or maybe
even the original resident evil upon
booting up the system and diving into
the main menu you're greeted by the
bright color scheme of the original
Playstations memory card and CD player
menus I'll be it with a carousel of the
20 available games ready for perusal so
far so good
pick a game and your seconds away from
revisiting some of the most iconic games
of sony's debut console that rear
adduction however may not go as smoothly
as you'd expect as someone who regularly
plays PlayStation games today on both HD
and SD displays take it from me the
PlayStation Classic will give you a
false negative impression of what
PlayStation games should look like even
if you don't want to go to the trouble
of playing with the real thing you can
always emulate games on a slew of
devices including a PlayStation 3 and
have a far better experience than that
of the PlayStation Classic it's well
known that mid-90s 3d games can look
rough around the edges so it's not
surprising to see jagged 3d models and
crummy textures on the PS classic you
may also recognize the familiar screen
door like dithering effect over large
parts of the screen but because you are
playing on an HD flat screen and not a
CRT the effect is very pronounced all of
these caveats are part and parcel of the
PlayStation experience and could in
theory be forgiven but not in practice
the PlayStation classic is configured in
such a way that the overall image is
rendered blurry at 720p to the poor
image stretching which consequently
muddies up graphics that were already
borderline ugly to begin with perhaps
the most disappointing aspect of the
PlayStation classics implementation is
that some games exhibit framerate issues
Tekken 3 is the most obvious example and
as either because the system is poorly
optimized or more likely that the game
is based on the PAL release from Europe
their analog video standards limited
refresh rates to 50 Hertz NTSC regions
including North America and Japan rant
60 Earth's a regardless of the cause if
you're used to Tekken 3 running at 60
frames per second prepare for additional
disappointment going back to the notion
of playing on a CRT the difference
between analog and digital displays is
one that can almost be overcome with the
help of a scanline filter that blinks
every other line of resolu
lots of emulation devices such as the
NES classic and SNES classic for example
offer this setting it's a divisive trick
that doesn't suit every player let alone
every game but it's a nice option to
have when faced with games that are made
unsightly due to the increased scrutiny
when playing a 240p game at 720p
sadly the PlayStation Classic doesn't
offer scanlines likely due to the fact
that the image is seemingly rendered
before being stretched to 720p hence the
overall blurriness if sony has indeed
opted to display games of aya that
assumed tech pipeline i would love to
know why the frustrating thing about the
PlayStation classics basic configuration
is that it's based on a well documented
emulator EPS X II which supports a wide
range of options to help you tailor the
handling of games to your liking want to
add anti-aliasing or change a native
resolution you can do that almost
anywhere you use the emulator but not on
the PlayStation Classic Sony has
effectively left options on the table
that could have made a big difference
when it comes to actually playing the
games you're feeling nostalgic for rough
images on screen shouldn't totally
overpower a great game though right in
some cases you can still find enjoyment
after you get over the initial hump of
disappointment Ridge Racer type 4 is a
snappy racing game with pilot wing-like
vibes and a great soundtrack all of
which comes across on the playstation
classic mr. driller super Puzzle Fighter
2 turbo and intelligent cube make for a
strong trio of puzzle games that are
even better when played competitively
great reasons to put the included second
PlayStation classic controller to use
but if grands single-player adventures
are what you're after
Final Fantasy 7 or Wild Arms r2 RPGs
ready and willing to give you dozens of
hours of classic RPG gameplay Tekken 3
might not have survived unscathed but
thankfully not every game feels as
sluggish as it does during gameplay you
do have the option of using save states
and emulation convenience that did make
its way on board to suspend games
wherever you are and pick them up back
later
there are virtual memory cards assigned
to each game that function like software
based versions of actual memory cards
both of these solutions work as expected
thankfully after you've spent
considerable time with the PlayStation
Classic the simple included controllers
start to feel inadequate compared to
full-featured Dual Shock controllers the
PlayStation have those way back in 1997
dual analog sticks vibration and all
these weren't defining qualities of the
PlayStation experience at large but some
games do suffer by their omission I'm
looking at you Metal Gear Solid that
point lies at the heart of why the
PlayStation Classic goes from being an
enticing curio to
disappointing missed opportunity in
short order the debate over selected
games aside using the PlayStation
classic feels like partaking in a rough
recreation of the original PlayStation
experience and if you spend any time
with Nintendo's classic consoles you'll
see the user experience here for what it
is just good enough the PlayStation
Classic doesn't feel like a celebration
of Playstations formative years the way
Nintendo's systems do nor is it a smart
adaptation of a capable emulator working
behind the scenes I would like nothing
more than to tell you that the
PlayStation Classic is a pleasant
surprise that it will match your
excitement and Mensa this sadly isn't
the case and short of Sony refreshing it
or the hacking community breaking it
open and reconfiguring it the
PlayStation Classic may never be more
than a puny PlayStation with good looks